Finally, I want to say a word about collaboration-based design.
When we did object-oriented analysis, we were essentially picking out
the important objects in the description of the real world.
And we're using those as the basis of deciding on classes and and
the associations among them.
And eventually we got to the stage where we were mentioning methods that
the classes might provide as services.
Collaboration-based design takes a somewhat contrary approach to things.
In particular it's concerned, it starts with use cases.
Individual use cases sometimes called user stories or scenarios.
And with these use cases,
each use case has various actors playing a specific role for that use case.
Collaboration design, by the way, is sometimes called role-based design.
So we can say that for a particular actor, participating in
a particular use case, that actor's fulfilling some kind of role.
So let's specify that role.
That role takes the form of the actions that,
that user takes in that user's story.
Once we have catalogued those actions, okay,
we can then examine other use cases that involve that same actor.
And from the set of activities which that actor under,
undergoes in the various use cases, we have built up a set of roles and
the combination of that set of roles is in fact going to
be what the overall capabilities that that class must provide.
So we can synthesize the classes from the set of roles we've
defined during this, this process.
I'm not going to go into role-based design any further,
but you may come across it in the literature or
you may want to look into it more yourself and, and try it out.
Because it can be an alternative approach that
might be helpful under some circumstance